it was by far the biggest snowstorm of
the winter in new jersey and
pennsylvania the snow hit hard and fast
and local officials urged people to stay
home and be ready for anything we're
prepared we've got plenty of food and
yeah we'll just hunker in in boston the
storm was being compared to a historic
blizzard 44 years ago that left the city
buried in 60 centimeters of snow
this storm seemingly packed close to the
same punch
it wasn't quite as bad in new york but
the city didn't escape unscathed the
snow left everyone and their dogs
shivering what is your name little guy
this is basil basil you're shaking are
you cold
oh my gosh
he looks cold
yeah
for the tourists in times square who
braved the minus 10 degrees celsius
conditions it was something to behold
i've never seen new york with the snow
so it's really wow like american dream
winter wow
i think it's awful but it's nice
while the snow is beautiful and it can
be fun to play in it also can cause
problems and be quite dangerous
this storm is being called a bomb
cyclone and it's affecting the entire
northeast of the united states where 70
million people live
at the coastal peninsula of cape cod
near boston twitter users posted this
video showing how strong the wind and
snow were blowing
close to upwards of 112 kilometers per
hour
storm surge was a concern in low-lying
areas all along the eastern seaboard
[Music]
once all the snow melts it turns to
water and officials warned of localized
flooding
throughout the northeast there were at
times blizzard conditions wreaking havoc
on travel
at airports thousands of flights were
canceled
and commuter train lines were halted
the storm is expected to taper off
meaning sunday will likely be the day of
cleaning up
warming up and digging out
gabriel rosando al jazeera new york